breathing's cuts up this is December
16th welcome to podcast Ville is the
Church of what's happening now
brought to you by necklace new podcast
behind behind the Irishman I told you
about the Irishman on Netflix I enjoyed
it I'll give a [ __ ] about the three
hours of 49 minutes a tremendous now you
can hear all about it how it was made
into an official podcast with my main
man Sebastian Maniscalco the Irishman
has De Niro it has Pacino
it's got Joe Pesci and again Sebastian
Maniscalco all three episodes are right
now today monday spoiler alert watch the
Irishmen on Netflix before you listen to
the podcast search for behind the
Irishmen wherever else you listen to
podcast watch the movie then go to
behind the Irishmen the church is also
brought to you by and I'm hooking you up
I think my [ __ ] Thursday or Friday is
the last day you're gonna order a gift
and get it because Amazon or wherever
the [ __ ] delivers gonna shut you down
but listen you're sitting there right
now it's Monday morning you're like what
am I gonna get my uncle for [ __ ]
Christmas and then picture yong-chol and
ask yourself does his [ __ ] stink like
[ __ ] death it probably does he's a
truck driver he gets in and out he
drinks a lot of coffee he's [ __ ] up
that's what hello - she comes in you
like Joey what's hello - she hello - she
is a portable bidet that takes you 10
minutes to install and it sprinkles your
ass with fresh refreshing [ __ ] water
no more paper no more cutting down trees
no more killing Apocalypto you know make
all of those you [ __ ] kill every time
you wipe your ass is 10 dead Indians
because who knows how the [ __ ] they got
the tree paper I don't [ __ ] know but
they saves you money on toilet paper and
the Terr she sprays your ass with fresh
water
not toilet water all right so she
connects to the water supply behind your
toilet just spray your [ __ ] ass on
the back back of your nutsack or ladies
you gotta get the back of that monkey
sometimes that [ __ ] juice dips into
the problem you gotta catch that [ __ ]
before it starts so do me a favor
they started $79 go - hello - she calm
slash Church and get 10% off your order
take this mother
muley it's Monday morning anyway what's
happening you bad [ __ ] I got
myself I got hey Zeus Trey Hill and my
main man the Christ killing the [ __ ]
house what's happening what's up you
guys thank you guys for having me again
absolutely this is a blessing man
we had a good time on a Friday we shall
we video and we laughed our asses off
you're a riot joy we're riding together
we [ __ ] oh man I like going off anymore
I don't like just playing commie no more
there's my life ain't no cyanide live
edition that's the worst [ __ ] show on
television I swear to [ __ ] god it's
not worth it was saying I live shoot
yourself if you wake up well you gotta
work on Mondays and tell your friends
how good is Alec Baldwin this weekend ah
take a [ __ ] black cop and shove it up
your asses over you're a dumb [ __ ] okay
I [ __ ] hate you Sarah right people I
have for a long [ __ ] time I'm happy
it's the holiday season I feel honest
it's like a week away from Hanukkah I
can you know write you like a week away
from Monica I also don't know what it is
this year it changes every year it's
like the 27 26 maybe the 20th will kiss
who gives a [ __ ] we're close look close
that's all that man yeah polish that
beanie how is that beanie nice it's
holiday season
forgiveness what's this [ __ ] what's
Hanukah oh we're just happy that the oil
lasted for eight days instead of one we
just want presents okay what's going on
with you kill it man it was a show time
yeah man midnight spots at the store
you're having oh [ __ ] man yeah man I'm
just happy man I'm just happy to be able
to you know do my thing do comedy things
are looking up you know just a blessing
man it's it beats pushing a lawnmower
not that there's anything wrong with
that but it's like hey man I've been
able to kind of you know make a living
from from my IP intellectual property
yeah I mean just think about some and
manifest it make it happen you talking
about the fields earlier yeah man
talk to me it's crazy I mean you're out
there working I mean I remember going
out there was my Mexico or no no here
I'm born and raised here okay I'm born
and raised here in Long Beach California
but you know my parents came from Mexico
and uh yeah my dental escena law and uh
my mom from Jalisco so I mean I pretty
much had the upbringing of uh of a of an
immigrant you know Spanish my first
language and I have command of English
too like what fifth grade cuz I could I
could speak English but it's like it
still was a little rough you know he
just kind of figured out so you just
kind of learn English translating from
the folks you know in the morning before
we went out to go work we'll go to a
donut shop or 7-eleven and I order
everything from my dad or for the guys
he was he brought to work with him and
then you know we drink coffee laugh it
up it's about to be 7:00 a.m. that's
when you can start that's what your
father's company yeah it's a landscaping
business hope so was the landscape yeah
it was yeah we regarded cherries or
something like oh no no yeah I mean we
did a little bit of that like you know
taking out grass putting out sod you
know taking trees out so we'd like we
would work the fields as far as like
planning stuff and hold you now 33 you
think about that work ethic when you
doing comm me like to you yeah oh yeah
ma'am I'm so grateful my dad was a
hard-ass tough love all day the
definition of tough love you type it in
my dad comes out arms folded you know
and thanks to that I think I was able to
apply it to comedy you know it was like
if I was able to be out there and
working with my dad 12 hours no problem
you know we just stopped for water
breaks eat listen to the radio in
between spots if I could do that I could
I could yeah I could go on the road I
could do this I could do that
I'm I don't stop even to a fall I mean
we were talking about this earlier how
sometimes you like man I need a break
today like I didn't just sleep in a
little bit and yeah I've been able to
transfer that into comedy and it just
been you know he's been a blessing that
I can multitask that way and not feel
the fatigue what's the dude who walks on
charcoals is [ __ ] the dudes I walk on
isn't that I Robin yes Tony Robbins for
example you know Tony Robbins seminar he
speaks about triggers
for performance you know and it's so
weird like I have a problem you know we
all have insecurities and we doubt
ourselves I have a lot of doubt even
before you go onstage little insecurity
you know just a little right touches and
I think that one of the triggers one of
the jobs that I always go back to his
hot carry hot carry for a minute when
you work for a cement guy that built
okay your shirts off right you could
taste the salt from your body and you're
freaking like you've been sweating since
9:15 and it's four o'clock and you don't
give a [ __ ] you're outside you're
picking up bricks
you're mixing mortar and it's easy it's
hard hmm
but at the same time you just enjoy what
you're doing that it's easy right and I
compared that before I walk onstage
sometimes like I think of all these
things like I'm so petrified before I go
onstage so that's why I was act a skin
you how is working that feel that
immigrant mentality helped your comedy I
mean last night you did five spots got
easy five [ __ ] spot people got moved
to New York to do five spots in a night
and just to be clear I mean these spots
weren't like packed with people I mean
there is no they never are yeah they
never are
one of them was the ice house was packed
but you know it's great I yeah I think
just that mentality it's like you know
just moving forward and not being phased
because it's like I know I know what
it's like to have to go to work with
your dad and be sick you know it's like
you have the flu or you have there so
you have a headache it's like it doesn't
but it don't matter man who doesn't my
dad had to go to work no man it wasn't
matter that's what people understand
that we've become very classified
you know I'm persephone you get sick
come on down right puke here and then go
back home then we're cool I was raised
under that mentality you know I pulled
my hamstring for the first week I didn't
do nothing then after that I knew I got
two options instinctive curl in me I'm
not gonna sit here and I got an excuse
not to work sure or I could work around
it yeah do other things
to everyday that's very scared you know
and then I realized you have to give the
like blood for it to heal you know like
you'd have to it's so weird how the show
must go on you don't have time to bleed
you know I tell people that me and Rogan
really have nothing in common except for
one thing
and it's it builds our bond so much and
that's called a religion of comedy
religion of calm I'm a Catholic yeah
I'm a Santeria guy and I believe I'm
full of boys but I was raised
when did you start cause there's two
questions I have for you right okay
don't answer when did you start comedy
and when did you start doing comedy
there's always two questions or has
always two dates for me I started comedy
July of 91 one that I really start
calmly when did the religion sink in and
I was like this is it
that's a great question rain snow shine
birthdays anniversaries no weddings
yeah I'm selling every possession I got
just a [ __ ] force because this is
what I want to do yeah I started calmly
July at 91 I started doing stand-up
October of 93 right that's when I go
okay I just got i baptize myself right
and I'm in the religion economy what
does that mean that nothing else matters
everything is revolved calmly is first
cocaine was a tight second neck-and-neck
cuz he was a tosser you know but the
comi a religion the religion of comedy
was first that was it I drove to
wherever I had to go like whatever
hustle I had to do when would when did
it snap for you
so I'm 33 now I started comedy when I
was 20 right so I had just turned 20
like I went up for the first time when I
was 20 right kind of did it bomb my ass
off real bad
got scared didn't do it for a whole year
and I came back at 21 cuz that's when I
can get into the bar illegally and I go
up then I bombed harder than the first
time I'm like [ __ ] all this [ __ ] I'm
gonna stick with school you know I think
my dad
on to something with this school [ __ ]
the whole ecology yeah yeah I was gonna
college end up graduating but I remember
even when I graduated I grabbed my
diploma gave it to my folks I'm like
this is for you I'm gonna go park cars
and my dad threw a fit he said that's
what you wanted to do like why you
wasting time and money it's like you're
you're gonna all my sacrifice you're
gonna go park cars at the store why did
you want to park cars at the store cuz I
can get stage time and I wanted to get
past and that's how Mitzi had the system
in play you know you do
potluck which back then was Sunday and
Monday so if you got Sunday you weren't
gonna get up Monday so that freed up my
Monday I could do another open mic but
you do the open mic until you're
basically tapped and I like hey do you
want to work here [ __ ] yeah I do want to
work here and that meant I had a
guaranteed spot on potluck Sunday and
Monday now right and that was three
minutes of stage time that's six minutes
between the two and then you get one
development spot in the belly room
that's another three I'm up to nine
minutes maybe run the light every once
in a while that's ten minutes you feel
me
a week sign me in so I worked the store
you know I hung out for a year begging
Tommy to let me work there I mean
begging hey Tommy
hey Tommy and as soon as I was coming up
to the stairs time it was like wow I
know I know you're gonna say I'm gonna
tell you the same thing I told you
yesterday
hey just putting it out there man I was
annoying I've never been that annoying
with anything in my life but when you
want to get into the religion economy
that's what it takes you know why did
you want to do it so bad you wanted to
be around you 24/7 you want to chew it
live it spin it it was it was it was
what I wanted to do and then like the
gist a track record of the Comedy Store
I mean you know some of the guys who I
looked up to came out of the Comedy
Store it's like you have Richard Pryor
coming out of there and then somebody
who I became enamored with and I never
got to me but God rest his soul
Freddie Soto I'm like I identified so
much with Freddie so does like well
where did he come out of the comedy
store well what did he do he drove
Richard Pryor around and he worked the
story yeah that's where I needed to be
you know you have Jim Carrey coming at
it Sam Kinison I mean the list goes on
and on it's like it's all day
and I was like III need to get in there
you know Rogan was there Shaffir was
there you're there the psych it's tried
and true I need to get in you know and I
got in and I did it I did every job I
parked cars for a long time did
maintenance work during the day I unclog
the toilet how long did it take you to
get fast low over two years so I can
[ __ ] in under in under three years good
for you yeah so I started when I was 20
but I started started comedy September 7
2012 that's when I got passed and I knew
that that's when it started cuz I was on
the road I was on the road I was I was
on the road I I think I was in Chicago
we were driving cross-country me and my
homie uh khal rhae and we're just
driving across town we had a gig in Des
Moines Iowa
at the funny bone and then we had a gig
at a Pittsburgh improv right and there
were a week apart so it was this week at
Des Moines a week in the middle free and
then the following week it was
Pittsburgh so we drove it took us a
month to go there and back so we do we
do Des Moines we were opening for C
Torino and we drive to Iowa we do the
show then we go to Chicago and we stand
there for a whole week and we're
sleeping in the car one of the best
times of our lives we're sleeping in the
car eating like an gas station hot dogs
and coffee in the morning splitting a
pack of doughnuts here and there by him
you know gas station bananas just to eat
healthy you know
and then so we do Pittsburgh and then on
the way back we're in Chicago and I
remember this we were at a coffee shop
at a Borders bookstore at some mall who
knows where I couldn't tell you and the
names go up and I think it was maybe
Brenton who sent a picture of them
painting my name on the wall cuz I
already got passed right so they're
painting the names on the wall and I
couldn't be there for the names night
ceremony and I was bummed out I was like
[ __ ] man I'm on the road doing you know
open mikes
Chicago in between just kind of waiting
for the gigas I was so bummed out and uh
and again Kyle was like this is what you
want to be doing I was like you want to
be a comic right I said yeah and you
know started thinking about it's like
this if I if I really want to be a comic
I'm right where I'm supposed to be I'm
on the road doing comedy as opposed to
being in town at the store is seeing my
name go up I got a picture of my name
half written on the wall and I was like
all right that night we went to downtown
Chicago and we did some some short a bar
that I eat [ __ ] at but I got offstage
feeling great I'm like wow they have no
idea like I just started comedy right
now like this is this is the day and
yeah to answer your question it was
September 7 2012
that's crazy 12 year difference of
thinking procrastinate you started the
store in 2009 yeah yeah that's what yeah
that's around when I started I don't
know exactly when I started but I was
doing open mics in Long Beach I was
driving back and forth you know just you
know I was working I was working jobs
here and there I was working at a steel
factory I was working retail I was
working like whatever I could get my
hands on working with my dad on weekends
but during the week and then eventually
I got a job as a PA instructor I was
working with autistic kids and just
three to seven I was going to school I
was like essentially hands-on teaching
you know and I would get out at 5:30 or
6 o'clock that's peak traffic hours here
in LA so it would take me if I got out
of five it would take me damn near two
hours to get to the store but that's
where I needed to go to go do my spots
that I'm working there at the store and
I remember during those times Chappelle
was popping in so it would go late we
were there 3:00 4:00 in the morning I
got a drive home sleep be at square 7:00
in the morning and do it again and it
was those weeks where he would pop in
multiple times I'm like it's just what
it is I remember one time my
dombarris caught me sleeping in his car
I moved this car cuz I move with cars
around and he had the heaters on and it
was cold I just stood there and I was
like knocked out he opens the door what
the [ __ ] are you doing sleeping in my
car like oh my bad my bad let me go sit
in my car but I mean what makes us do
that great a hustle you know there's a
big guys the
what makes you what possesses somebody
who look if I go home and my daughter
isn't work I can go to turn the key
right I keep breaks in the door that's
one thing I know I gotta sleep in my car
alright but you know I'm saying yeah you
call the locksmith he wants eight
hundred cuz it's 2:30 in the morning you
know but now the landlord
you know you get him at eight so what do
you do you crawl in your car you hooded
sweatshirt like an hour to sleep what we
know okay so you get pissed off eight
minutes right you put the music on the
heater and you pass out what makes you
get in the car knowing you're gonna
sleep at Chuck station and some chick is
gonna come up to you some chubby chicken
for more knocking the glass and go are
you looking for a date and you know like
not really huh you filthy animal and
there's a bunch of guys shooting Matt I
mean when I used to pull until those
truck stops they were crazy
really and I would have a knife what's
the name of that truck style I don't
think we stopped there
you name it you name it you know I mean
you go to some truck stops and see gang
activity like a guy going into the
bathroom and they're like a guy going in
and walking out but that guy still in
there another guy going out and that guy
stolen then another guy going on and
you're like wow and you're they roll
like you're just a different kind of
bathroom attendant yeah like here on
your joints in the other a box of change
so you could get like one of those
[ __ ] chips to like a cone well
people's bugles huh I still remember
living off of bugles and like Subway
veggie and cheese like it's so funny
it's so [ __ ] crazy like what makes
you I've asked the last three comics
that come on here like every second ask
that question for sure and it's it's
knowing that there's there's this book
by David Lynch and I don't remember the
exact title it's like finding the big
fish or catching the big fish and it's
just the thought you know you let all
these little fishes go by it's like
you're
fishing you catch one you let it go and
that's a day job it's this opportunity
it's an office job yeah I mean you let
all those fishes go because you know
there was a big fish coming and that's
comedy
and for me seeing guys like you rogon
you you know look at the LIA Brendan's
job like deal Vaughan you guys caught
the big fish and I know that yeah I mean
it's like and I know that there that we
catch the big fish because you guys are
doing what you love on your own terms
that's the big fish you guys are doing
comedy you guys are doing what seems
right to you yeah I mean look at your
podcast how amazing this is
I mean I'm blessed that this is my
second time here the first time I was on
here your audience was so warm no
they're very warm there is set on
Twitter they're like welcome to the
church God's Word they believe in all
rush it this is our thing you get to
create asses out there people are on
your wavelength nobody's telling you hey
Joey
the sponsors thing you can't read it
like that no well they're happy to do
business with you they're happy to
listen to you week after week you caught
the big fish you have a wife you have a
kid you have a family but do these
things just happen are they luck now are
they persistence you know I believe in
the universe I believe the universe has
a set a certain strength hmm and I
believe that if the universe sees that
you're really [ __ ] suffering you know
but you're not bitching you know the
universe perspective neveress hates
crybabies pro right and guess what I was
the biggest crybaby of them all because
I know what it is to be in love I know
what it is to break up with something I
know I know what it is to be cheated on
and those feelings you get in 1994 I
found what would calmly so hard like
nothing else mattered right like you
fought I could take falling in love with
a woman you know I was watching the when
you watch the Motley Crue movie talks
about falling in love and
my warmth that he never had grown up and
that woman was called heroin for me what
it was cocaine right but the real true
addiction was the love I had for comedy
not to be a comedy star not to leave him
live in LA just to be good right just to
be a good comedian I didn't know what
time was I didn't know what time limits
were hours 45 minutes I didn't know
right I didn't care about all that [ __ ]
when most Pete it's really weird when
you're 16 and you find your mother on
the floor and there's no one you're the
only person has to take care of you you
learn real quick what things you need to
drop from your life for you to survive
yeah there was no more football on
Sundays there was you know when I got to
high school I did that thing but I hate
it I did the thing that was uncool to
doing the seventies the most uncool
thing you could do in the seventies
well-labeled you were losing more than
putting the tattoo on your forehead that
said loser was quitting high school
because of my mother's death and because
of various other things I quit high
school yeah and it was [ __ ] painful
you know I am when when you're already
tagged to be a loser like people quit
high school were losers or not
necessarily their parents had a business
and they were getting groomed to take
over the business when they're 40 you're
still a [ __ ] [ __ ] you know I am from
school but uh but pain I think makes a
thing called it's like situations like
the one you described gives you a sense
of urgency that I think people don't
really move with and you know we've
talked about my parents health and stuff
from a very young age I figured out that
hey man this is gonna be different
IIIi can't be up playing video games I
can't you know do this and that I can be
hanging out I can you know you sacrifice
because you know that if there's gonna
be some kind of relief to the if you're
gonna stop the pain somehow it's gonna
be through
work and that's what you figured out and
I think a lot of people have figured out
when you find the thing that you love to
do and they you know that that thing's
gonna provide for your loved ones most
importantly and then you can get a
little kickback from that to was like
great you know I came here with a lot of
people and 50% of these people are still
here today and I look at what they're
doing and I look at what I'm doing and
I'm not here to judge nobody but I see
the differences in career paths and I
question you know like it makes me feel
shitty but I question what path that we
take that we ended up in different paths
you know like you know why I might let
the commies tour when most of the guys I
got put up with aren't even allowed on
sunset the guys I got past with my
they're not even allowed on sunset I
don't even think they don't cover one
guy I know for sure isn't an out of a
[ __ ] cuckoo farm that same that I got
past he's in and out of a [ __ ] insane
asylum right now well Combee just ate
him up and chewed him up and spit him
out every one every 90 days you see him
on Facebook I'm back he draws a picture
of a guy with a missing leg or something
but it's just like it you feel guilty
huge southern name you know Friday I was
there with Freddie you know well I was
trying to find my identity and I saw
Freddy go from driver to being on tour
with everybody you know
grab all those and then doing his own
tour and right I still remember being at
the Houston Comedy Festival with him and
him being on the floor under mine and
and [ __ ] it was all held out there
you know and it's I think about Freddy
from time to time I see Corey now a lot
yeah
Corey's been up there shaking those
titties a half so yeah 15 years later
you gotta come on shake those teddy hubs
and as I said Barry do you struggle with
like the survivors remorse or know what
you call it survivor's guilt of sorts
like I know you you were kind of
touching on that it's like guys who you
started with or got past with and
is that something you struggle with yeah
sometimes I don't know if it's luck I
don't know what I did right because I
did everything wrong but you see I did
everything wrong but I did one thing
right I put my head down like a go I
kept going I never gave up every year I
added to my arsenal I saw what people
weren't doing and I tried to add to my
arsenal early on I knew I wasn't gonna
be louis c.k they would not gonna let me
beat louis c.k and I wasn't gonna let
myself be a little sure like not by
taking my dick up I mean the sound level
like yeah you know the addiction
problems I had wasn't gonna let me beat
louis c.k but i kept showing up at the
store for a little money every night I
didn't give a [ __ ] about that I didn't
know when I was following morning all
those years and going to Felipe's and
all those guys rooms and anything up at
the store I wasn't thinking of the one
theaters on the weekend I just want to
be funny
alright that's what people get lost they
start looking past that and your call is
just shut your [ __ ] do me a favor
just shut the [ __ ] up just shut the [ __ ]
up until you do half kind of a buffalo
saber game until that time don't say a
[ __ ] word cuz you don't know dick and
that's where I would go down to the
store early and the guys that weren't
getting up it's just negative its
negative and it's a reverse guilt that
you're on and Dan are not well Mitsy
likes you yeah what do you want me to do
yeah are you insinuating that I [ __ ]
her and neither asked nor I didn't I
come here on Sundays I make sure on the
Sundays my game is on top minds in here
seeing the old days she were coming
during the week Wow
they would tell you it when you got
there nah Mike Mitzi's coming
[ __ ] you know yeah then she'd sit there
and you know like thank God please and
he would actually get people to go talk
to him yeah a favor go talk to Mitch
he's giving away spots we'll talk I
would trick people won't talk to like
that somebody go talk to oh yeah you
wanted her to see somebody you stood
next up and body block behind Mitch get
the [ __ ] out of here
I'm saying go take a [ __ ] hike you're
in no danger getting a spot mitts he'll
die before she gives you a spot in this
[ __ ] dump you have a saying like they
was just right whenever she was there
she created this [ __ ] energy and they
were coming from all over the place so
when you know think about [ __ ] think
about parking cars right Mitch he comes
in at 9:30 on a Tuesday and at 9:45
there's no comedians of the blowing and
she's sitting in man she's hot break me
wanna pick my feet up being on she
people picking a little Jewish feet up
you should put on the stool yes she sits
back there's nobody there it's 9:45
ain't nobody gonna talk to us yeah and
she watches your whole set and you die a
death of [ __ ] 10 Katrina survivors
achy you die like one of those [ __ ] in
Orlando you just get you just get [ __ ]
shot in the head dog and you walk off
that stage man why I said that usually
one you would just look at the carpet
yeah just walk down go looks like I'll
be parking cars for a long I'm gonna get
used to it yeah I put a little how to
drive a Tesla I tell people all the time
I used to leave they're going with tears
I still remember going on that hill to
fountain mm-hmm making that left turn
down again yeah it's here just going
down my face like what it's like I won't
be at this door no more it goes have
they ever unpassed somebody like painted
over their name on the wall or no
I saw her throw a few people out there I
know she took Jerry Seinfeld out there
yeah he was on there last week yeah yeah
yeah you can't recover I remember the
time he came in and he told the story on
stage you know this is maybe a few years
ago but it was like you know 30 years
ago just he came he came to LA he was
too polished for her yeah to the what
yeah to polish for her she didn't want
you Paula Jesus he basically quoted her
and said that it's like you know you
come here to LA he's like and no one's
gonna no one has told you no he's like I
want to be that person to tell you know
he's like and he would drive down Doheny
in his Porsche and she would be out
there watering the lawn and they just
kind of lock eyes like what she never
would let him play and then you know
this was a few years ago and he went
onstage he said this is my first time in
a long time crazy and now he went up
recently actually within a week right
[ __ ] Jews hating Jews it's a [ __ ]
Horror Show I think
Mitzi's like strong aura built better
comics at the store it was it was that
fear of I better not bomb yeah
no other club had that I mean what
Freeman wasn't doing that the comics
right but Freeman's out there this
[ __ ] monocle people not bothering
anybody
I'll never forget being in Miami and
Budd Friedman was talking while he
honest with Stan and this had to be 99 I
walk in I covered for somebody they got
cancelled when I was the feature and I
could cover I would sell tickets down
there that ah I had like a little white
bike from going feature work people come
and they knew I snorted coke and I'm
gonna forget that Budd Friedman looked
at maybe standing right next to Stan he
goes hey look what it is and he goes
what's this kid's name you know those
are the things you really can't explain
to people right like you feel like going
go [ __ ] yourself but you're like I'm
working I'm getting 1200 you know saying
right I can't blow this this is the
biggest paycheck I love the sea in my
life right right right
that's so funny man yeah the store is
such it like I've I mean you've been
there longer than I have and seen the
transformation but there's something
very special about that place you know I
haven't um a different person I have a
loyalty problem if you did something for
me systemic substantial at some point my
inner Catholic Cuban Indian roots make
me very loyal to you I call I call
certain people who were there certain
parts of my life and I tell them
whenever something good happens because
I didn't want to let them down
they were there for me they covered me
at a certain spot in my life and my life
I have a teacher named mr. t I call him
first he doesn't my [ __ ] you know
sophomore year teacher hmm I took him to
the premiere of [ __ ] something I did
you know and I think the longest yard I
mean he was such an impact on me comic
comic wise but there's always been I say
about 12 people
Jim handy he got me into comm he was a
car manager at a car place that's where
all those people I tried to call him
when something good happens because in
the back of my mind I'm doing something
good for them I want them to be proud of
me I don't give a [ __ ] about anybody
else I don't even [ __ ] about the jars I
want them to know what they did for me
was not in vain yeah I want them to know
and wouldn't Mitzi died you know it was
like Mitzi and Brody and it was just
like a weird thing yeah but it was it
was three deaths let's be honest it was
the death of me on Netflix death mid see
that the Brody it was three deaths and I
say how it is I I tell you how it is I
was there I know how I thought when I
got off that stage you know whatever I
don't care Netflix is never gonna use me
again but it was three deaths in one but
Mitzi's death affected me yeah because I
really she died I didn't go to a funeral
I didn't want to be around all that
but I did think about what she meant to
me and I said Wow
she changed my whole life because of the
store I mean I could take it this deep
because of the store I have a daughter
hmm I met my wife at the store I met Joe
Rogan at the store right i met ari at
the store my Paul Mooney at the store
Melanie Griffith at the store you know
not to insult anybody doesn't like I saw
you and we we had a really good time at
the improv a couple weeks ago the first
time you were hosting that's the first
time I stepped out of the store in a
year well because after Mitzi died and
after my death on Netflix all right B
this is how this is how you have to be
though you have to be able to laugh you
can't live forever thinking that you're
a [ __ ] you know the [ __ ] Johnny
funny you know I'm a special bomber I
bomb on specials but I kill at the
original rule you know as I am devastate
the original room I'll shoot you down
but I bomb on specials that's my thing
that's my thing some people next time
make sure the special I got a call a
bomb alert I have like three Iranians
day with long beards and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] giving out hummus chips and [ __ ]
so they could get the blame ah that's
what
Mitzi's debt [ __ ] me up yeah because I
realized what she had done for me her
Sunday night talks you know I was the
host
so in between I would have to go without
at the list and go do you want hey
sister go on god no you know she went
says I don't want three spots is in a
row like I don't want three black guys
there or three Mexicans in a row so I
would change it up with her you know I
don't want three pieces of [ __ ] this
girl's too pretty put her up at the end
like she just had this science right she
just had science like she had done it
all before
just press what I'm saying to you yeah
and every once in a while I'm not gonna
lie to you next week I want you to dress
like Fidel Castro and put a handcuff on
like Sunday yeah
forget by Wednesday okay I want you to
do Latino night and dress up like Ricky
Ricardo and get a blonde and shake her
ass and expect it you know she was crazy
you're gonna say everyone so all she had
but every once a while she would just
say next time you say that joke don't
say that word even if it's offensive
like [ __ ] like that like [ __ ] them
Wow but you're like really and she goes
yeah that's the word that's needed there
why [ __ ] the joke up right and I will
call Wow you know she called my wife to
farm a girl the fargo my wife the former
girl and she called my she buy that
she's was a farmer girl like me that
tough and she called me fat baby fat and
then she put my name on the list is fat
baby I still have the schedule so you
got brought up as fat baby that baby Wow
she didn't bring me up as fat baby they
brought me up as Joey Diaz but nobody
would know who I was in those days so
she's like his name is fat baby I'm the
schedule so it was a fat baby on the
seat when did you fully dish the fat
baby like how long before once she
stopped coming around okay that's when
the name took a death you like I like I
just want to wipe I didn't kill a [ __ ]
yeah call me Vic [ __ ] flied [ __ ]
whatever as long as you give me six
parts a week at The Comedy Store ramen
at this time I didn't gonna Montreal
right I had [ __ ] Chinook his son his
grandfather as an agent you know I had
[ __ ] Johnny Rotten as a manager nobody
talked to me nobody born for anything
that's why I started doing movies
because I said I'll figure out going
through the backdoor you look at mine DB
it's like I know it's a six the house
I'm gonna pack a bomb IMDB I've been
shooting [ __ ] since 2003 and where I
stopped what gave you the foresight or
what what let you know that that was
like the I guess back to our way and I
knew they didn't want me for no comment
nobody wanted to talk to me as far as a
community nobody not even [ __ ] shitty
see we labels Wow
I finally a guy by the name of Victor
lop God
so I'm a big-time the Mexican Cuban
comic from the store big time seventies
Kennison fistfights static Porto Ricans
lost his leg and you know he looks like
something of Vietnam like an armistice
shirt on real tough guy nobody's sure
you know was a guy that if if I got the
soprano will be able to call big dumb
[ __ ] big well hop was one of those guys
that was he was the original cast member
Richard Pryor show you know like one of
those guys he pitch snort coke at the
store with Elaine Boosler oh yeah all
those crazy [ __ ] I mean he had
stories forever he had like this little
side company in Vegas if have a now I
called the Blue Album it's me with two
chicks on the cover
that's who put that CD out came in the
first chance they would pay you like
7,000 minutes so I just did like 2,000
minutes back there with flares that
lights siren I wouldn't get off the 7000
minute watch me go [ __ ] chords
and kwame's like we kept like 58 minutes
I was on the [ __ ] couch so they paid
you on minutes they gave you in advance
like 750 ya a page on minutes and then
every truckstop you got in the country
there it was a CD that's where I make
their mind now they're really pushing it
and now I'm not mad at them I won't help
them push it cuz they won't pay me
anymore
sure but they did give me a start that
was my first formal CD they did the
photo shoot it was a craziest thing
because it was like I taped it did get a
photo shoot then they stopped answering
my calls
for six months hello hello nobody would
call what and one day in the mail I got
a box of 100 of them and they were like
good luck that's it you'll never see
another dime again well you could sell
them have to show cuz that's what they
gave me a hundred of them to Psalm at
the show do you know how many I sold out
of those hundred I'm writing to I do
last away really I didn't have the heart
I took him out one time and
I need coke money really bad ah I'm like
please who are you selling for ten ten
and some guy came in before II is the
magical number table ball thank you
if you think I'm gonna stand back and
sell these things I don't give a [ __ ] to
be take him across we can get two hours
apiece and then I found the guy on
Sunset yeah I mean what they do pizza on
person
Sierra bony dancin sunset Gaucho not
Gaucho oh the Italian place yeah kind of
Italian next door that okay was it me
box yeah cheeba cheeba cheeba next door
the cheapo I can mine the Aether's is
like a frittata guy one of my batch he
wasn't all that happened - so like 99 or
something I won't buy one it's like I
you he's not ever made glass English
come in give me your autograph
aren't you the guy from The Sopranos my
Mike uh I tried to be mafia maybe my
favorite big [ __ ] gave me a hug he goes
what else do you do it I'm a comedian
goes nah really
he don't you gotta think this out so I
went home and I went back through this
thing I got these CDs and he goes well I
usually take these on consignment but
you're a Hollywood star I give you like
5 hours apiece he took like 15 and 5
hours apiece I'm like I'm never walking
on this side of the street again
somebody's gonna come in here he's a
town this is he I have a surprise I was
making that's not the [ __ ] guy was
soprano hi so he was he sees I come back
in six months we'll sell him for 15 and
we'll split it down the middle but I'll
give you a five up front he got me like
a check I went to the bank and [ __ ]
they cashed on my dad any one other
business
that was a check that took him on days
like [ __ ] put that money brought took
him for that minnows I didn't have the
balls to sell CD's afterwards but Victor
lop was one of those guys that yeah you
know Rogan is one of those guys only
some good happens I have to call him I
did from Friday I know he was in Vegas I
know he was getting ready for the Wyatt
yeah and I called him he answered we
must have talked
something about stand-up for like 35
minutes yeah but it's a freefall thought
I was listening to Ted Nugent
free-for-all and I'm like with doing
Tommy right now it's a free-for-all like
this I don't really give a [ __ ] like I
don't really give a [ __ ] all I want to
do is have a great how when I go on the
road right that's it I don't care about
a special I don't get about nothing I
just want to lay it on them I just want
them to leave and go Jesus Christ
where'd that [ __ ] old man you know
that energy from his line to his he's
doing blow you know but they're not I'm
not going up there talking just giving
it to you biting into your [ __ ] neck
that was all from Mitzi's Death Watch
unless he died it took me about a month
to realize what she had done for me and
what I had to do for her now in her
honor what I have to learn something for
her and my job is to be a comedy store
marine I'm that sniper that has to
[ __ ] kill you you're the guy I call
and there's eight of them up there at
the Comedy Store that she created and
built around Sebastian you know there
was a lot of guys that she really guided
she made snipers out of them right and
we're like the last guys that come in
the [ __ ] shoot you add off like when
we come in there guys dying right one of
these eight guys is I'm gonna take this
head off so we're good here
right that's how funny and consistent I
want to be like my whole mind that has
to be turned to funny like I don't even
have time to get sad or more right if I
get sad about some I flip little [ __ ]
joke like that's how serious I am ever
since she died
it did something it was like my mother
diet yeah I was at the end of the day
she replaced my mother at some point my
I had that calmness was your family yeah
they might have thought the Comedy Store
the pain I had in my leg
you know the thoughts about the two
weeks I had a cancel and you know I
can't lift nothing compared to the
overwhelming love I got that night from
the employees their how they picked me
up and they [ __ ] girls were [ __ ]
carrying me and they moved my car and
they called the next day they sent soup
it made me realize on party something
I'm nearly bother something that's big
it's big it's so big that it overwhelms
me still after 22 years like I don't
take the comm you stole for grant I'm 56
I'm still getting spots the [ __ ]
store suck my deck right so when I go to
st. Louis Kansas City [ __ ] the Fresno
next year Bakersfield I'm representing
the Comedy Store that's it I I don't
want to sell t-shirts I'm gonna sell CDs
after a show
Mitsy they might know that she admits it
even life's on the food yeah she doesn't
push for the food forever just dry
people can laugh if they have food in
their mouths
she lost money so you can have a better
show a pure Shama diya Steph you
understand me you know so that's why
when people go to me you to you you're
leaving so much money on the table not
bringing somebody and give them $10 an
hour what I want to do that I don't want
nobody I'm [ __ ] shirt salesman okay
that's number one I'm not telling
anybody enjoy sure itself I'm not this
is nothing a comic the damn sure and
making them a shirt salesman if I'm in
fact to sell these shirts I have to go
out there and that takes energy away
from me so the people who paid 24 hours
after your finals for the second show
you know what let's eliminate this shirt
and let's give them the best show I
could give them if they want to sell
this shirt all my wife my wife will tell
you whatever love
my wife will give me a picture of a
[ __ ] with me autographed my wife 8800
for a picture of a [ __ ] with an
autograph from Joey DS and comes in
black and white so we got all of it
please say that I'm ashamed of you why
you never told me then Miesha Tate had
nude pictures I didn't only stand over
the podcast sent me nude pictures you
have to see a little buzz before she was
pregnant her after I don't know it was
delicious
you pass the bakery look at a cupcake
yeah push it in and show [ __ ] Hazen's
trade oh you're gonna Derek oh you're
gonna die somebody sent me a link and
they go Joey did you see these almost
fell backwards off my shirt there's a
picture or a laying backwards and her
[ __ ] is shaved and that's just laying
there and you walk past like a bakery
and look at the doughnut and go wow wow
that's a pretty [ __ ] doughnut it's the
same thing I'm gonna how [ __ ] look so
[ __ ] turn on the screen I have to find
it first we should take nude Google and
spell me [ __ ] with a pillow and tape and
make sure you spell nude with a capital
I don't think I never saw no like that
man yeah top not some guy sent it to me
a messenger I don't get messenger all
the time I don't get messenger but why
itself no no no wait till you see this
one picture of a [ __ ] not this one not
this one with the good boots look at
this lead lead look at this you're gonna
whack least China red already oh yeah I
already put all my [ __ ] yeah it's good
[ __ ] oh forget this keep going up forget
all these look at the one on the far
right and look at that [ __ ] cake look
at that imagine walking by and seeing
that little dab looking at you tell me
you're not gonna stick your tongue in
and go [ __ ] submit me you dirty [ __ ]
look at it I love me she's no disrespect
you have a bit of me shove you listening
you have a [ __ ] tremendous little
pop-tart because that is some beautiful
little [ __ ] look at this guy's look at
got hair on it yeah it's not on the
video you're taking down the video
version they are using YouTube up oh I
didn't know then look at that picture
that I don't like I don't like that's
too real like no I see like a foot I
could smell it I don't like it look at
the yes look at the farm that's she's
fine
look at that tremendous me should take
[ __ ] beautiful I never saw I would
never even disrespect me should take I
do a podcast I do her radio show the
once in a while so somebody just sent me
this decade Wow a radio show
did you see these nudes when I saw Uncle
joy would say tremendous you see a
little crumb guy walking you business
you thinking about going on vacation
yeah you stopped at a bakery window and
you're like man that [ __ ] Apple
turnover looks good a lot of making
meatloaf right now people didn't get no
[ __ ] on one day [ __ ] go down little
on your thumb back one out in the
bathroom
you come out with sticky fingers next
thing you know the tea sticks so much
the tea sticks on your computer it don't
even take capital T's for you you got a
copy and paste have it on the clipboard
cuz you can't push the button oh how is
shooting your Showtime special what does
that get released you think Showtime
special issue it should be like the end
of first quarter next year so I think
like March end of March okay you decide
about it I'm excited man I this is a big
dream come true I mean since I started
comedy that was like you know you dream
of having a special and you know it came
a little earlier than I expected you
know 13 years then I thought maybe it
was gonna be a little later but it's
like I'm happy in 13 years it takes you
seven to become an attorney
but you know it's like it takes a while
to find your voice and it was just like
alright well I can't pass up the
opportunity I gave it my best shot I
would go down to the we work spot I got
a little we work community space the
cheap thing I would go down there people
will leave the office after 5:00 so I
get to use all the whiteboards and I'd
write up the whole set from left to
right the whole thing and just to get
ready before every weekend I do that
Monday Tuesday Wednesday before every
weekend I would go on the road to get
ready and I just broke it down 20 20
minutes at a time and I just took it
very serious I there's nothing [ __ ]
getting in the way it's so crazy like
nothing we got in the way van it's so
crazy how I lived in a building in 2001
with the browser man I live the Ralph
form and a bunch of people on this
building and they would have little
parties and stuff and it never really
like I said to myself I didn't come here
to go to parties right I didn't come
here to go to barbecues I came here the
base we can't get our [ __ ] stage
what's that that's me I would just write
the whole [ __ ] thing down I was I got
looks like a beautiful mind sort of
thing yeah I would get obsessive man
when he does the math works oh yeah yeah
with the suicide kid Robin Williams
babies yeah you got nine [ __ ]
shoplifting days left and I can't make
the [ __ ] off-color joke about suicide
point number one well yeah Showtime
special coming out soon it's the
neighbors
home son catch several it's a
stay-at-home son state oversight yeah
you tight with your father
yep time with my mom and dad you know
you live with them still yeah you yeah
head [ __ ] you say bone right you
said [ __ ] this [ __ ]
no no thank you thank you for listening
to young people Joey I've been telling
people forever listen do me a favor
there's nothing out that give you better
advice if your mother and father were
still alive
go over there one day to eat and tell me
you all look at the basement you think
you looking for a trophy and just paint
it put a bed down and moving this time
I'm moving and they're gonna argue you
cannot move in we told you you're a
grown man I don't give a [ __ ]
get me out easy monk me let me [ __ ]
I'll give you this I'll be the laundry
your parents saved the [ __ ] 1800
it's no fun having a roommate and trust
me living with a bunch of bitching no
funny that she's a broke [ __ ]
and then the paying double she's always
[ __ ] broke she can't pay the phone
bill mind your business
[ __ ] chicks and cars and live with your
parents and the car yeah that's the move
on just [ __ ] them in cars bathrooms you
fight you over with your parents bro you
find the way to [ __ ] people outside go
for it yeah yeah you get creative anyway
you need [ __ ] and you look at mom you
[ __ ] the [ __ ] in under the garage you
understand me like why not take some of
that money to save to get a hotel for
one night because you're too cheap
you're living like a doctor okay my mom
[ __ ] turns that brillo [ __ ] up on me
if my mom was still alive and have like
a little belt next week when I get in
bed at night eyes ringing she puts the
blanket over me sana colita Lana
she knows her son
you know saying like isn't that weird I
live with your [ __ ] parents do not
leave there's my mother huh I wasn't
gonna Californian you know California is
18 on your foot studio apartment Oh a
lot utility what's your budget 1800
that's three rats and a one-bedroom no
actually bad
that's three rats in Brooklyn in a
studio apartment a basement apartment
and you're gonna freeze yeah stay at
home with your mother I don't give you
the buyer Dubuque Montana stay there
build your own little comedy community
if you build it they'll come yeah that's
real but all these comedy festivals
everywhere it's like there's a festival
everywhere yeah calmly is alive and
comedy and everywhere you know everybody
wants to do this and get themselves in a
[ __ ] predicament and you know what
this career is tough enough you're right
how many is tough enough so anything you
could cut out of your life that will
give you keep low head low low overhead
so you could live on nine hundred a
month you know when nine hundred spike
and you're living like so what's the guy
on Gilligan's Island the house remember
they were rich other words Humphrey yeah
you call them [ __ ] mumphrey you tax
returns like I made 9600 or you do show
up and they'll give you food stamps
right but you live in at home with mom
so you're like I don't mean no food
stamps 9,600 my car's bought and paid
for you got one of those old Toyotas
you've driver yeah you know you got the
general general general he 60,000 bucks
right racing coverage $30 of my throat
on a Mexican y'all leave the country
basic coverage yeah you know it's it's
weird
stay at home try I don't give a [ __ ]
I'll tell me by you stop all right I'm
gonna have stage time yeah he'll live
with three [ __ ] stinky dudes and one
of them is not gonna have the rent every
month right stay at home
Cobra does teach you that I wish that
makes you really smart with your money
it teaches you how to keep your overhead
low low low cause you know
you know they're not them you know what
I used to do I still have my 24 hour
fitness but I knew that I needed a gym
membership and you pay the extra 10
bucks to get it out $45 a month I would
fly in to do colleges and so there's a
24-hour Fitness near every major airport
in the country that's a fact
right so you fly in to whatever Kansas
City you're about to go do a gig
somewhere you go in there you take your
morning deuce workout shower go do the
gig you come back you spend an extra 10
bucks on the on the on the rental of the
vehicle so it's like a SUV you can sleep
in there you go back to the gym workout
shower up you return that and you just
saved yourself a buck 50 on a hotel I
mean I used to 24-hour Fitness a--'s
were my go-to you were broke but you
went shaped like a [ __ ]
back then office and had no shower
yeah so I had to join the gym yeah and
I'm a clean dudes I'm on them to shower
minimum a day yes mine 3 but I just
wouldn't go in there and shower you just
can't go on in an office don't you know
play it off a little things I do some
yeah welcome yes I would hit the punch
him back in the morning I would hit the
punching bag in the morning and lift
weights at night right you know and then
take a shower and that q-tips was on one
of those gyms yeah yeah you tip bowdry
mouthwash
yeah opening the other in tears like a
dead hair on there you take it off with
a baby man and then you would steal like
shaving cream I don't leave like raises
real good [ __ ] shaving cream edge oh
the one that was grinning I turn a
different girl I used to rob edge from
that gym on the costume guy we go we
gotta put a camera back there somebody
keeps the only egg do you need dog when
you were comic you take everything just
think a dog I remember I ain't gonna say
the dude's name he's a millionaire today
I still remember doing a gig with him
for a weekend and every time we go to
eat he'd steal every package oh [ __ ]
that's great every time the cancer sugar
the blue pack the
back and the regular sugar and the brown
cane sugar just in case when you're on
the road you have everything in your
trunk yeah well my car got towed my
apartment when I lived in Hollywood when
I would sleep her right in the car in
the shower Ralphie Mays hmm everything
was in there everything that would be
necessary in case of emergency flares
apply is a frisbee a basketball a
football and a towel for the window and
a pillow you know a set of change of
clothes blankets and you have them
tucked away perfectly I mean there is so
much [ __ ] in your trunk that if you take
I mean it's perfect you know whatever
the fisherman even had right you always
prepared for it I had a car that the
radiator with blow oh gosh I'm gonna
have to put those capsules in the Radian
and aha sit tight for a half hour and
then start the car they wouldn't leak
anymore would plug the radius right ever
have the little shades and they're
shaving down there so you just learn all
these math things and you learn about
overhead yeah you start I mean I I think
I still have the notebook from like 98
when I was homeless I mean I wouldn't
even file for taxes and I didn't file
the taxes 91 to 2003 and I live down
there and I told them the truth and they
gave me a number type a law they do cuz
they you only go back seven years okay
so they don't give a [ __ ] if you made
three other thousand one year but
they'll find you oh they'll find out
yeah hi books are tight they got eyes
everywhere but if you really do learn
that I'm getting I'm picking up five
hundred hours this week
right that's what I'm picking up for you
know there's some clubs that are still
playing beaches 75 bucks mm-hmm that's
real but you knew exactly where that
money was gonna go you know it's like
even on the road it's like even if I
wasn't staying at one of the nice hotels
that you would stay at when you were
like featuring and you're doing a
one-nighter you keep your hotel cards
you know walking strolling at like 7:30
in the morning
hello Holiday Inn get your little
continental breakfast and get the [ __ ]
out of there
I mean with a with a muffin in your
pocket yeah yeah oh yeah you got the
paper underneath your arm yeah I'm just
waiting for that of all of you thinking
you're coming through the back yeah so
you watch this somebody to go up and
back to and you come right in you walked
it off right yeah he's standing here if
they ask something like most times in an
adding event because it can't yeah I
mean well you're there and in case it's
like are you or are you a guest here
yeah absolutely
how's your day going you know real
friendly um great uh sorry have a great
day I got yelled one time no way the
only goes up to 400 are you sure that
you let me see you this this is that a
Marriott what it's called I got married
at one of those those married I wasn't a
marquee it's the those extended-stay
joint yeah like one of those there's one
in Boulder I got mammy that married
courtyard
Oh Corey our courtyard Mary okay yeah
those and help me I still move being one
behind
I still remember living behind the wall
in Detroit
Wow and the guy was because after a
while you like I said the universe takes
Kay okay so you gonna get you know like
I totally some nights you go to a gig
you pull up on a Thursday you get in
there and the guy says to you where
you're gonna stay I don't know I'm gonna
find the hotel after this don't worry
about it my mom's got a basement come on
over there let's go we go right what but
they sometimes you you know two out of
52 weeks I'm gonna go somewhere nobody's
gonna talk to you after the show Ryan
you're like I got 125 hours the room is
80 what's the play here he helps to play
here I got a gig tomorrow night
I could live it in the clock I hit that
cold I can go in at my stake
it's a night you know and I'm not
talking about a nice steak I'm talking
about a sizzler step right right and
then you'll smell hair on it enormous
snake yeah like a norm steak yeah don't
get one of those then you go back to
your car like I still remember all those
times like yeah okay I remember one time
we were on the road it was again cow a
cow ray and I so we stopped in Boulder
Colorado right we got no money which by
the way we didn't even have money in
Chicago to get through the tour oh you
know how you throw the change in the
basket we're digging in the cushions I
mean we're throwing at it to see if it
opens just penny here finally it opens
we're like we're good we do the gig now
we have money right so we got a hotel
room and then a I think it was gonna be
our second day we're really tired means
I hate man I'd like to you know go out a
hotel or some rest out we can shower
Baba we'll split it great 80 bucks you
know for the room he finds his spot on
his phone we go in there and the guy you
know smoking a cigarette inside sketchy
sketchy spot so we get the room for 80
bucks we go around back we go in there
we open it door there's a dog in there
there's some like swim flippers on the
ground and there's a lit cigarette in
the ashtray in the room Kyle loses it he
said what the [ __ ] is is he slams the
door we go downstairs like hey man you
gave us a room and there's a dog in
there he said what the plug there's no
dogs allowed here it's like oh you're
worried about dogs there's other [ __ ]
going on here you're worried about a dog
and he's like well well we can give you
an another room he's like I want my
money back he's like no refunds man
he said you [ __ ] cusses amount
so he gives us another room we stay the
night and he's looking at these reviews
and one of the reviews was hey look
underneath the bed there's one time I
found a used needle full on needle Bob
us and we're like looking we didn't find
anything but it was bad the doors did
not lock right and he was like look you
know upset so we shower up we get ready
we sleep with our clothes on
cuz this place is so sketchy if [ __ ]
happens
you know we're covering ourselves with
the blanket feet out just in case you
got to jump up and he was so scared
he's like the door doesn't lock I'm like
[ __ ] lay just sleep we put a door up
against the door handle of the door I'm
like look if somebody opens the door
this thing will tip back I'll make
enough noise will pop out of bed so we
just sleep we're [ __ ] in our clothes
he's in his bed I'm in my bed we sleep
6:30 in the morning uncle Joey 6:30 in
the morning
the chair boom boom boom boom we're both
on our feet wait what the [ __ ] Kyle runs
to the door because it doesn't close but
you put the little chain on there so it
opened up this much and if they would
have pushed a little bit that thing
would I can't write the [ __ ] off right
so Kyle runs to the door the doors open
this this buddy start yelling I don't
know what he's yelling just like I'm
barking through the thing and you just
hear steps and he like opens it and we
posed pop out it was a cleaning lady
poor little cleaning lady he's like
let's get the [ __ ] out of here bed we're
already dressed we just got our bags got
in the car kept driving but that was the
most miserable stay ever in Boulder
Boulder Colorado man I wonder where the
[ __ ] it was a little motel after yeah
off the road somewhere it was it was bad
in it and he's like man that was a worse
$80 spent well we paid 40 apiece it was
crazy man but those stories are great
you know that what you explain to people
is that all those stories involve
problem-solving they involve
problem-solving and disappointment lots
of it yeah so once you get that twenty
five times and two years once you get
deeper into this they don't seem as bad
as what they really are
right you know like I lost an eye well
[ __ ] it last week I lost an ear you know
like right yeah you we're not surprised
by any lies by anything no more and
that's what I explained the people that
journey toughen your skin all that stuff
toughen your skin you know you get to a
place sorry there's only one room you
have to stay in the room with the feet
you go in there
his feet stink he smoking Marlboro Reds
you go to your car you know you gotta
fight with the kids I'm not to smoke or
whatever they did all that stuff toughen
you up for later right when that movie
guy tells you no he didn't get to move
it right you know all those little
things because they're big thing we're
starting comedy right and you look at
the itinerary you gotta drive 12 hours
in between gigs you're like for $100
spike you're like I'll do it but [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah all these things prepare you
for late if the right disappointment
later
so the disappointment isn't that intense
on you yeah and that's the difference
going back to the things like a lot of
comments are posted I'd you know like
you were saying it's like when
somebody's like hey man you know your
spot got cancelled that or you're going
up at 1:30 no more like [ __ ] it's like
really that's what you're choosing to
get upset about I'm not gonna lie
anybody yeah at one time at this store
right there was one time when things
weren't going great yeah and I got a
really frustrating like don't [ __ ] I
gotta wait because I think there was a
water clock spot like I was so used to
12:45 12:30 now it's 1 o'clock [ __ ] and
I thought you know I think I'm just
going to stop calling up and that's it
right now
take that take a billboard not a Bilbo
like a chalkboard uh-huh and put it up
outside and tell him you have a 1:15
spot at this store and you don't want to
do it so many people sign up cuz I was
like that's riche a yeah and that was
the last time I complained about time
you're there you're there yeah yeah
that's great yeah okay you're calm
you're not supposed to do those two or
three one of those all right let's do a
story anyway you're getting home you're
not doing it right I were to look
through anyone cuz you and you guys
gotta go on eat afterward and talk right
about what happened yeah you bombed
tonight yes no I did that Chuck work
[ __ ] you know that's part
oh that's part of the gig the gate yeah
that's part of the night what was your
go-to spot after a show like where you
would like me to when I first got here
yeah what was the hot spot a hot spot
after after the shows and
and Fairfax passed the acting school in
the middle is a 7/11 and they used to be
a little [ __ ] photo shop place that's
where the security Hut is but in there
there's a Mexican restaurant where the
key shop yes yes okay I know exactly
that's a gas stations right there right
yeah next date but there's a Mexicans
might respond now now it's really bad I
said okay but when you're a regular in
the beginning and that 15 yeah his
[ __ ] gold our big thing was to go
down there and sit at the three Mexican
way they would chase us out and that's
how I got fat I would sit there yelling
grape juice and she'd give me unlimited
like I drink 12 grape juices
I just drank twenty-five coca-cola's at
the store yeah
you know I just really drank 19 pokes at
the store with a wine minute last night
no no this is Georgia you know that was
part of the that was father so we would
go there was never a norms guy if Rogen
would take a soppy we go to standard no
sir and get the blue cheese burger oh
that sounds [ __ ] delicious the
romantic tale yeah that's when Rogan was
like you want for a hamburger and you
act like you weren't hungry and then
sometimes he found somebody to go with
him you [ __ ] guy would say yeah but
if he wanted you to go to go come on
just sit with me and talk to me you're
like how cow go it's in the waitress to
come you want a menu meanwhile you're
dying inside you can't bring chips it's
also something yeah yeah ever got the
waitresses fingers you're like I'm
[ __ ] dying here what about the first
time something to you and you were broke
oh you didn't know you look at those
numbers you assume that they're gonna
pay for dinner because they're a
big-time headline
and you're sitting there going oh like
water water and you're like okay I'll
get the steak and you're sitting there
going I hope he doesn't give me the
[ __ ] check and make all of this those
are the worst I remember when I got the
longest yard before they gave it to me
they called me and they said we want to
meet you at the Four Seasons Hotel in
Beverly Hills guys so I had like eight
dollars in my pocket I get their valets
20 it's [ __ ] June it's like I have two
horrible audition or meeting memories
that was one of them when I got there
and they're like 22 Park I'm like 20 and
I was in my pocket Matty and I had a
bunch of quarters and I go I'll be right
back when I go to the ATM or [ __ ] ATM
there was no ID and then I just went to
some [ __ ] place and found 12 parking
yeah I had to walk to the yard to the
meeting and by the time I got there I
was trans and sweater that's it in the
hallway and they're like what are you
here for you know it's like a
four-season I'm walking in there with a
big Daddy
sweat gear on the face ha ha for free
every factor in town at Big Daddy gear
yes Steve Simone knew the dumpling guy
that's for every fat [ __ ] had big there
that's how I when they sent me a box
clothes I'm like I don't need to buy
clothes for a year
yeah I wore Big Daddy shirts underwear
swept then they were thick yeah so you
ball sweat your ass wet oh it was that
black velour oh yeah and I'll never
forget walking in there and they're like
eat and I got the lobster ravioli I'll
never forget this at the four seasons
before Sebastian and Sebastian ain't
there just in case I can borrow money
from Sebastian you know I'm saying like
40 I don't know what the bunch was yeah
and it was Adam Chris and P the seagull
and then I eat much and I'm like okay
and the whole time I might hope they
don't go for ways I hope they don't go
for ways on this check because I got $8
when I saw Adam picking up
oh the heartburn went away like an
heartbreak have some cheesecake I'm like
that's another $22 Oh
I'm gonna be walking this is what's the
bastion I'm looking for surpass the
amount weight of it yeah yeah so I'm
looking for Sebastian like Sebastian
listen if it goes under can we put this
on a tab I can pay you tonight is
something like that's how petrified that
was well there was loss of batna another
time right after 9/11 they changed the
whole Sony thing okay it used to be that
you have an audition in front of the
gate 11:00 they would let you dry after
9/11 they made you go that way part and
then walk back yeah and it was
spider-man 2 it was April it was 95
degrees and there I am with a sweatshirt
with a black Big Daddy velour warm-up
suit ah and I'm 390 every hundred and
ninety pounds and I can feel the sweat
dripping on my back and my ass I could
feel the swell of my back mixing with
the leftovers [ __ ] in my ass when your
ass get spicy yeah bad like that spicy
ass my ass
let me wipe your ass that's the little
[ __ ] on the paper residue on yeah oh my
god [ __ ] horrendous Trejo I want to
thank you for being for doing what
you're doing I want to congratulate you
on being a regular when I congratulate
you and your work but uh I appreciate it
man I think it's over and I got the call
that you would doing videos for these
guys I was very happy because people
don't understand that it's this simple
keep doing what you're doing and then
you would see a conveyor belt yeah see
like Toy Story or whatever it's like
Detroit all of a sudden one day you
actually fall under the conveyer belt I
don't know how many times that conveyor
belt has to go around before you get off
that's your decision it's your decision
when you get on the conveyor belt and
it's your decision once you're on the
conveyor belt that does not mean you're
in bad shape that means you're Dean
right your haters trailer you can't
Quigley you Steve Simone you're you know
I still number run his easy when he got
20 [ __ ] screen tests and couldn't
book a TV show he was on the conveyor
belt you're on to convey about you
worked you did the work to get into a
comedy store you did the work together
for the improv you did the work to get
into the Laugh Factory you did the work
to get a manager to hire you you did all
that work now you want to convey about
that conveyor Bo could go for eight
years what could go for 12 years the
rest is up to you for me that conveyor
belt took like seventeen years cuz I was
a [ __ ] addict I was fat I didn't give
a [ __ ] you know it took a longer than
others for some people could be three
years for some people they hit three
years they got HBO special they get
cocky and then they get back on the
conveyor belt and now they're on that
conveyor belt for ten years they got to
pay that do on the conveyor belt so just
because you got a little success in you
fell off the conveyor belt didn't mean
you know I'm saying I forgot to convey
about six years ago and I had to go back
on after the all right be Netflix and I
had to go back on the conveyor belt and
then I had to decide when I got off the
conveyor belt again what did I have to
do to get off the conveyor belt this is
what needs to be done
boom now I'm off the [ __ ] come bad
though you did that you got in the
conveyor belt congratulations it took
you how many years thirteen okay now
you're gonna convey about now you decide
when you get off and it's hard work and
it takes a one person to see right you
got the store you up there one thirty
your girlfriend dumped you
your mother's shoulder she slept she
broke you're on stage you get off
Chappelle's going on he tells you not to
leave you sit through his three-hour
[ __ ] himself when he tells you you
doing the North American tour time we
don't
every day right my life good your life
could change in that and that quick of a
thing yeah so now you get the 23 nights
with Chapelle so now you have to think
about it's not just 23 nights with
Chapelle you're going up to further
cream of the [ __ ] crop audiences yeah
but a pain are hundred and something
dollars to see chappal your goal is to
retain 5% of that audience every night
now you have a new dilemma
you're always set with the lightness you
always set with dilemmas it's not really
an accomplishment it's an accomplishment
and wrapped around a move
you know Rogen's gonna take you out now
for a year that's 10,000 people we
coming gonna see you in an arena if you
can retain 5% of that it's 500 people
next time you do an import now you call
an improv and say let me get one night a
little 500 people to one of them they're
[ __ ] are hurt they can't make it but
300 will show up you just started your
[ __ ] Korean with 300 people well
that's all this and this all applies to
everything this is not just calmly when
we talk about this we say calmly this
applies to every function right whether
your attorney a carpenter you a union
carpenter you fall into the conveyor you
get the work every day you stay in an
hour late you work the overtime you work
Saturdays one do you get made of Foreman
the same [ __ ] thing right the same
[ __ ] thing and what happens is for
comedy like my religion is comedy
for some people their religions aren't
like Jennifer Jones for some people who
religion is a campaign like Bob Wallace
well Linda's you know everybody has
their own religion Dave I'll even put
your roof over your head and you believe
in it and you get better at everything
that you do it you know you're on the
conveyor belt congratulations bro thank
you little [ __ ] show what is the taco
show
come on stuttering so tacos con todo
comes out on complex
the trailers gonna drop end of February
I mean I mean end of January and it
should be out January and it's gonna be
just you know comedy going around eleyne
and and looking at some of the best taco
spots out here and really dab it into
the history it's done in the right way
and there's some great people behind it
just and bolas has been putting his his
all into this project and and also I'm
very grateful for people like you took
time out of your busy schedule my laughs
what up for me oh I couldn't really
Shaab [ __ ] die oh man I was I was
telling you earlier that's when I knew I
had to quit smoking cigarettes cuz I was
laughing so hard just I mean you were
going on one of these amazing rants and
I was laughing so hard I couldn't catch
my breath there was a hot two minutes
from like I'm gonna die right yeah that
story I told is the truth right now I
got four flies and a weed and I feed
them weed yeah everyone so long when I
take a [ __ ] and it doesn't hit the water
yeah I take like a piece of stick and
I'm putting [ __ ] in it a little can so
they survive AB attack but then we we'd
most of the time I cut one wing off to
give them like a little I'm like a half
a Hitler like I cut one wing off you
know I got my own little private flyash
oh it's funny
[ __ ] I can I tell you something please
I saw Joey move like mr. Miyagi there
was a fly on the table he's looking at
he puts his hand up just waits like two
three seconds go pow anything cuz he has
big hands you think like they would fly
away he does he gets like mr. Miyagi
like kill bro bro for my life he flies
all my life especially God oh you guys
have to see the episode once it comes
out but I mean I was blown away how
quick you all I hate fly that's my left
hand right flies and sometimes I scoop
up out of the air a couple weeks go up
slam right in my wall okay dog I had 300
flies in my house
nah we gather around
the window and I just sit there for
about an hour let them gather like they
all bathing like [ __ ] pop yeah like
they're megwin and my wife has a
flyswatter she's an amateur she's over
there point that Adam I said what's the
master worry I want to got a book the
bent oh okay I started by the row not
the first great Freddie so don't had a
joke out of this father would step on
roaches and he would leave him there
oh yeah to tell the other flies that we
don't [ __ ] around in this house
that's right yeah like I believe sweep
them up no no no no no no leave him
there that way sighs no I'm not [ __ ]
around and it got to the point that I go
how many more days that we gonna have
flies and she's like two more cuz they
took the possum out and then the gnats
turning to fly I don't [ __ ] know the
whole scientific [ __ ] whatever the
four or five days bro it must have
killed 50 flies a day just going after
pop pop I would walk in close the door
make believe I was going into the
kitchen and I come back with that book
flying out of my [ __ ] green heart
what's his name
hard to find though I would be smacking
a Bob for the time and then I'd step on
them you dirty bastard tonight sweeping
outside ones over half alive I'd take a
half a wing off and burn them you have a
light him on fire I don't give a [ __ ]
just a second fly above American flying
race there's gonna be a [ __ ] be there is
something like dick dude anyway you have
any a website they go and see yes I got
me yeah hey sue strangle calm my
Instagram and has to strangle number one
Twitter and hey Suz Trejo
were you for New Year's I'm gonna be at
the Ontario improv doing both shows so
please come out oh [ __ ] yeah and I'm at
I'm doing the weekend at Sacramento
punchline this coming weekend I'm doing
Thursday one show Friday to Saturday two
and Sunday I'm back home so please
please go check that out I would love
nothing more to see you guys there how's
it true Hazel's trail thank you again
for being a gentleman thank you got a
hard worker thank you for being thank
you for what you do man I I'm AXA can
never you know Mexicans don't break that
back
you can throw a Mexican off a roof you
ever say mixing with a broken back never
never you don't exist
you ever see a Mexican a Jew gold chain
and back brace
you never see a [ __ ] Mexican with
Jewish gold oh that's what they call I
was like I'll race you never seen a
[ __ ] Mexican walking down the street
with a neck brace saying ISIL I still
know nobody ain't got time to go to
court that's eight hours off the clock
that means they lose 50 to get fifty
thousand and two years forget it I'll
get the 50 on my own it's so funny it's
just as Mexican people were so stubborn
my dad they gave him a neck brace cuz he
had some problems with his vertebrae
just from working so many years he put
it on he took it off and he's like man
my neck hurt someone you're supposed to
wear the brace is it so uncomfortable
hilarious
put it on I bring you comfort know the
itches okay we'll deal with you it's
it's hysterical I love your parents I
love that a bunch I love it man all day
you love you [ __ ] parents hey
Zeus Trail calm hey sue straight with
the Connell yeah my dates
I got a few tickets left at the Senate
Performing Arts in San Francisco I'm the
28th Colusa sold out the 21st is sold
out then we start enough I think the
15th and 16th I'm in Fresno and
Bakersfield and the 25th of January I'm
at the Tabernacle Theatre they added a
second show that's all I got beer but
before we go anywhere
the church is sponsored by netflix new
podcast behind the Irishman I've told
you all about the Irish run a couple of
weeks ago on Netflix some of his life
that whatever I listen I think it was a
tremendous movie now you can hear about
how it was made with the official
podcast
listen to me Patchi was tremendous De
Niro was tremendous
Sebastian was great I mean I loved
everybody in the movie the other guy
that when I was married to Lori and
bracha that plays Angelo Bruno he was
great on this podcast you're gonna hear
from Charlie Brandt the author of I
heard you paint houses find out how he
uncovered Frank Sheeran story
and learn why DeNiro fell in love with
the book and and how they got Joe Pesci
out of retirement get an inside look at
all the tricks they use to DEA the cash
for you we'll all comic-con
nerds and whatnot behind the Irishman is
hosted by a member of the church family
and one of my dearest friends I wish him
all the luck in the world
in fact he's gonna be at the forum
January 11 Sebastian Maniscalco he's
hosting behind the Irishman so do me a
favor
all three episodes are out right now
today spoiler alert listen watch the
Irishmen on Netflix before you listen to
the podcast search for behind the
Irishmen wherever you listen to podcasts
watch the movie then go listen to behind
the Irishmen again my main man
Sebastian's on it so you gonna enjoy if
you wanna listen to the Irishmen that's
all great and Danny but right now you're
sitting there thinking about what to get
for people don't give them a [ __ ]
gift card I know Russians right now on a
computer stealing off all the money off
you give God that's what they do all day
long all day long and steal money off
gift cards everybody has an [ __ ]
every deserve is the gift of touchy
wiping your butt with dried toilet paper
come on what are we [ __ ] caveman it
removes this [ __ ] but it leaves the
stomach in juice you ever come on your
girlfriend's foot and you take the thumb
off at the fullest thing she's like like
it's bleep I give people the purple
birth marks on their faces [ __ ] it's the
same [ __ ] day water cleans better
than the papers oh no it's not this is
me talking to you [ __ ] listen
to she is a [ __ ] horrible birthday
it connects right here toilet patient
ten minutes you don't even need I think
you need like a wrench or something like
they no plan no nothing
they started $79 all right you get a
90-day guarantee 60-day guarantee
it don't matter I've had one for four
years if my big stinky ass hasn't [ __ ]
and [ __ ] up that tushy your little
skinny bony ass will be [ __ ]
tremendous you like Joey why everyday
and white tushy why cuz it sprays water
directly into your [ __ ] ass I'll
think of my nice warm water going up the
[ __ ] how would you feel you're going
through a rough time your grandmother
died they left you the patio furniture
forget all that
they come up getting hot water sprayed
up your [ __ ] who's better than you
you know why you need that cuz all day
long you're sitting there like a Mook
with bacteria growing in your [ __ ]
and that creates nasty things like ten
boys in fact that pop mine yesterday oh
oh oh that they lose that went to lift
some weights and [ __ ] a little so you
know what the wipe my ass there was
little blood thank God no more yeast
infection no more UTI but most
importantly no more itchy ass holes
listen there's nothing missing I ran
into ten years in jail and have an itchy
ass or no arms no I have an itchy ass
off you can always get something
stretching back you'll die before
somebody scratches your [ __ ] not even
your mother your mother lucky and say
you [ __ ] [ __ ] anyway listen go -
hello sir she's back time right now
Crescent Church and get 10% off your
order listen there's nothing like a
fishy birthday I know you got people
that you need a present for this is the
best present you know what they started
$79 so give it a shot take a chance
Columbus - go to hell - she calm and
press in church I get 10% off your
[ __ ] order alright you never
use the Toshi's now is the best time
start the year with a clean [ __ ]
you've never done that before you filt
the animal I'll see you guys Wednesday
you got nice shoplifting days before
[ __ ] Christmas Thank You Hazel's
trail for coming on Thank You
[ __ ] but most importantly then
call you [ __ ] and don't forget
to look at Misha Tate's [ __ ] especially
that up close well listen it looks like
a little bagel with no locks listen look
look like an everything bagel a little
stumble a little everything kick this
[ __ ] melee